good evening good evening everyone I'll
never forget the moment I was 12 years
old at home watching television on a
rainy Sunday afternoon and they were
showing John Ford's the quiet man it was
the scene where John Wayne is in a
horse-drawn buggy
being driven by Barry Fitzgerald coming
home to the land of his birth Ireland
and he sees Maureen O'Hara across a
field surrounded by sheep first time the
Jukes Shawn Thornton's saw her in the
film was also the first moment I laid
eyes on her his character had never seen
beauty like that and neither had I I
don't think a romantic leading lady has
ever been introduced on film by a
director to such stunning effect he
still gives me goosebumps whenever I see
it for anyone anywhere around the world
he loves movies he is more than simply
an Irish movie star he is one of the
true legends of cinema a woman whose
skill and range of talent is unsurpassed
she is one of the most adventurous woman
who ever lived she loved to fly in a
seaplane with her aviator husband
Charles and she was the first woman
president of a scheduled airline in the
United States she is a self-described
lifelong tomboy he was a pioneer and
doing her own stunts and film after film
mastering complex fencing and fighting
routines
she made westerns and musicals movies
based on Christmas and ones based on
literary classics comedies and dramas
and in every film her eyes were riveted
to her every moment she was on the
silver screen
she started in black and white films and
later became the queen of Technicolor
leaving us mesmerised not just by her
performances but by her fiery red hair
and gorgeous green eyes
Oh God just get lost thinking about my
first crush
again and Maureen O'Hara did more than
just fascinate me she enthralled and
enchanted every leading actor and
director of her era from Henry Fonda to
John Ford to Jimmy Stewart to John Wayne
with whom she made five movies for the
entire command for the entire Academy
tonight is the chance to present her
with an honour richly deserved for me
it's a chance to thank her for giving
hope to a kid from the town of ballerina
county antrim that maybe one day he too
could end up in motion pictures and it's
a chance to say to the woman who has
long had a place in my heart and in the
heart of everyone from our island 6,000
miles across the sea I love you Maureen
we all do congratu